The delay in COVID-19 testing in the
United States meant that for weeks
doctors and public health officials were
flying blind about who was infected
and the location of major outbreaks. As a
result they had little hope
of containing the virus before it started
spreading out of control. Why did the US
fall behind almost every other country
in this regard? It's a long-standing problem
that's led to needless suffering
and loss of life long before the Corona Virus pandemic.
But in this case its
impact is so high-profile and far-reaching
that the episode could finally bring lasting reform.
Drastic measures being taken to try to contain the outbreak of a mysterious pneumonia-like virus.
The genetic sequence for COVID-19 was published on January 10th
by Chinese scientists and uploaded to
the National Institutes of Health's website
allowing laboratories around the
world to create their own diagnostic tests.
German scientists had one within a week, and other countries and private labs quickly followed suit.
The World Health Organization shipped 250,000 of the German version of the tests to labs around the world,
but the US Center for Disease Control decided it needed to rely on its own version of the test,
which would be certified by the Food and
Drug Administration, but it wasn't ready until early February.
February 6th and 7th, ninety tests were shipped to state public health labs around the country,
but the kits had a technical flaw and needed to be returned to the CDC for testing.
Meanwhile the virus continued spreading.
On February 4th, the FDA said it
would allow government-approved labs
with high complexity testing
capabilities to create their own tests,
provided they copy the CDC's approach
and send all of their results to the
agency's headquarters in Atlanta for
verification. Former FDA Principal Deputy
Commissioner Joshua Sharfstein told the New Yorker you certainly wouldn't want
to say any lab can advertise a
coronavirus test because then it's going
to be chaos there's a lot of people who
will sell things that may or may not
work though well-intentioned the rule
became a stumbling block every virus a
little different but this is one of the
more most challenging ones certainly
I've seen in my lifetime take the case
of Alex Gruninger a doctor and
researcher at the University of
Washington who sent in his application
to create a corona virus test via email
according to a report in GQ he then
learned that he also needed to submit a
paper copy and then another version
burned to a compact disc or loaded onto
a drive and delivered to the FDA's
maryland headquarters after he complied
according to
reportin Republica the fda didn't
approve his test right away they asked
him to make sure his tests didn't cross
diagnosed with SARS and MERS other
coronaviruses which hadn't been seen in
the US and years his test was finally
certified on February 29th
at which point the fatal outbreak in his
home state of Washington was already
underway as the crisis worsened in the
testing shortage drew headlines the FDA
simplified the process but then on March
20th they warned that they may shut down
efforts to rapidly make available at
home testing kits on the grounds that
they were unvetted and could be
fraudulent the first documented cases of
joven 19 in the u.s. and South Korea
were discovered around the same time yet
as of March 17 one out of 4,300
Americans had been tested in South Korea
it's 1 out of 17 had diagnostic tests
for Cova 19 been available sooner they
would have helped public health
officials isolate quarantine and provide
medical supplies to areas of the u.s.
affected by the virus
how could this happen this tragic
testing delay has brought national
attention to the FDA's long-standing
overly cautious approach to regulating
American health care to minimize risk
the agency is sacrificed speed
preventing doctors and patients from
accessing the tools they need until it's
too late the agency's risk reduction
over speed of approval goes back to the
1960s when a sleeping pill called
thalidomide marketed to pregnant women
cause babies to die in utero or to be
born with serious birth defects the
crisis was mostly contained to Europe
because concerned FDA regulators have
kept the untested drug out of the u.s.
United faith and the best and the most
effective food and drug law of any
country in the world in 1962 President
Kennedy signed a landmark bill
increasing the agency's oversight powers
it resulted in a culture of extreme
caution that led to long approval times
for experimental drugs and devices
keeping potentially life-saving tools
out of the hands of patients
the beginning of the movement to relax
those roles and rethink the trade-off
between risk and speed in the FDA
approval process began during the AIDS
crisis of the 1980s gay rights activists
were outraged that the FDA wouldn't
quickly approve more experimental drugs
like AZT which blocks HIV replication or
Athol it amide used to treat some of the
wasting symptoms of AIDS after lobbying
in protests including the 1988 shutdown
of the FDA building the administration
slowly began to loosen its rules leading
to the approval of highly active
antiretroviral therapy or Hart in 1996
because of Hart contracting HIV wasn't a
death sentence anymore
gay rights activism during the 1980s and
1990s created a framework for patient
advocacy to people with life-threatening
illnesses leading to the right to try
movement which has allowed terminally
ill patients to access experimental
drugs and devices that are still
undergoing FDA testing the movement
pushed the agency to streamline its own
compassionate use program to help the
same kinds of patients but the Cova 19
testing debacle underscores the limits
of those reforms once a full
investigation comes out about the
agency's failures perhaps it will bring
fundamental reform at last giving
Americans rapid access to potentially
life-saving tools
you